hey tom it's good to see you um first of
all
you are spider-man at all times the
physicality the stunts everything was
like so thrilling in this any injuries
a few injuries a few you know
bangs and bruises here and there uh i
got really bad tendinitis in my
hamstring which isn't a very cool injury
that's just from overwork uh which was
which was affecting at some points in
the film uh but you know my two stunt
devils are you know the best in the
business and yeah they make sure that
everything i do is as safe as it can be
and the only times i get hurt is when i
do something wrong
so yes i was i was lucky that i got away
with this one pretty unscathed
sorry
god bless got problems
just when you said doing something wrong
yeah i know just so i say do something
wrong i did bang my head really badly on
this one but oh
it was fine you can carry on we got okay
i got a sticker playing bang my head at
work today
get at school and they send you home
with a note
[Music]
how do you think
mark would do as a super villain in a
spider-man movie and would you ever want
to go up against him
no i would never want to go up against
wahlberg he is like he's actually tough
as leones
you know we're not actors like i can
play tough
i can do it and i'm convincing at it but
i'm not really a tough person whereas
is actually a tough person a lovely
person mind lovely great to be around
enjoyable company but he is genuinely a
tough person so i wouldn't i wouldn't
fancy my chances in a fight against mark
yeah you guys look like you had a lot of
fun on the golf course
i just had to slip that in there yeah
um you guys look like you had a lot of
fun i mean just the chemistry on the
film you can see it um are you gonna
grow a mustache at this point in spite
of mark
i if i grow a mustache yeah i look like
i should be
on some sort of wanted poster
for very unbecoming crimes i don't
it doesn't look good on me
i yeah
i don't even want to tell you what i
look like because it's so gross
um obviously in this film you're after a
fortune uh but what in your life would
you say is your most prized possession
i'd say
my friends all of my friends i'm really
lucky to have an incredible uh network
of friends of people that i've been
close to for a long time people that
i've been close to shorter periods of
time um and my relationships with with
the people that i'm closest with is
probably what i am most uh
is most valuable to me
i love that
were you a fan of movies like indiana
jones growing up i was like the biggest
fan but as a kid this was my go-to movie
you know like a family movie that is
about exploration that has you know
twists and turns big action sequences
for me this was my go-to movie so to
have the opportunity to make it has been
uh
has been a real dream come true
i love that are you ready to do a
trilogy of uncharted movies at this
point
yeah i guess so i mean i've done it with
spider-man and we did pretty well so
yeah i think i think i've got it in my
back pocket
jumping out of a plane like what do you
think is the next crazy thing you could
do at this point
it's one of those things where like
sometimes you come up with ideas for
films and you're like wow that's really
cool but how on earth are we ever going
to top that
you know you're always shooting yourself
in the foot that's why films like that's
why fast and furious they're now like
driving cars in space i've heard of what
they're doing because you've got to go
somewhere and so
i'm not too sure really i'm going to
leave that to the creatives and i'll
just make it come to life
love that thank you tom